in general the left isn't big on
admitting things even obvious things but
in the case of Robert Miller's
congressional testimony yesterday they
really don't have a choice tonight most
on the left are conceding yes it was a
total disaster for their cause
how was Nancy Pelosi reacting tonight
and what does Donald Trump jr. think of
what happened yesterday both of them
respond exclusively right here in just a
moment but first tonight the Russia hoax
ended yesterday we can say that it ended
not with a bang but with the muddled
half memories of a fading old man
slipping in and out of focus America sat
transfixed by Robert Muller's halting
testimony before Congress no honest
person could have come away at the end
believing that the president United
States colluded with the Russian
government to steal an election that was
the allegation you'll remember and then
after the most extensive investigation
in modern American history we found the
truth and so tonight we can say
conclusively once again what we told you
the day this all started the whole thing
is a crock it never happened they were
lying to you that's clear now the debate
is over but that doesn't mean the Russia
story has quite ended there are loose
ends for two and a half years some of
the most powerful people in America
supposedly serious well-educated people
very smart people these people made wild
and untrue and totally reckless
allegations about issues critical to the
life of this country all on the basis of
no evidence whatsoever it's hard to
believe they did that but they did do it
what should happen to these people now
congressman Adam Schiff for example
Schiff claimed he possessed actual
evidence of Russian collusion and he
didn't just say that one time he said it
repeatedly and there is significant
evidence of collusion there is ample
evidence and indeed there is of
collusion of people in the Trump
campaign with the Russians I think
there's plenty of evidence of collusion
or conspiracy well in the end you know
what happened or didn't shift did not
produce the evidence he didn't have it
because it doesn't exist Schiff was
bluffing which is to say lying
he still is actually as if yesterday
shift was continuing to claim that the
Trump campaign quote embraced foreign
help made use of it and covered it up
in other words collusion shifts still
believes the collusion hoax or does he
today Adam Schiff went on CNN to carry
water for his boss Nancy Pelosi
impeachment might not be a great idea he
told CNN's viewers but wait that doesn't
seem to make sense if Donald Trump is
working for a hostile foreign power as
Adam Schiff has told us countless times
that he is how can we not impeach him
no one's seen an asked Adam Schiff to
explain that contradiction unfortunately
not that it matters because think about
it for a second and you'll see exactly
what's going on Adam Schiff never
believed a word he was saying about
Russian collusion I suppose the good
news is ship is not delusional the bad
news though is that Adam Schiff is a
soulless liar he's a man willing to say
to literally anything for political
advantage and that's really the worst of
all being a lunatic would be much more
appealing than that naturally Washington
being the place that it is Adam Schiff
has been richly rewarded for his
shameless to see he is still the
chairman of the House Intelligence
Committee that's one of the most
powerful jobs in all of government ship
is all but certain to be there for years
but what about his enablers and there
are a lot of them the journalists the
pundits the fellow lawmakers who helped
Adam Schiff tell his lies these are the
people you remember who blithely accused
the sitting president United States of
treason the evidence suggests indeed
Trump is has been a pawn of the Russians
but when you start to see a pattern
where he basically spouts Putin's lies
then we have to ask the most unusual and
frightening question about our own
president why this president seems to be
putting Russia's interests ahead of our
own
well Christi the president's tweet
trying to make the case that he's not a
Russian asset really just undercuts his
own defense
the president's tweet couldn't have been
scripted better if it was written by
Putin himself this is nothing short of
treasonous because it is a betrayal of
the nation he is giving aid and comfort
to the enemy is their influence whether
witting or unwitting by the by the
Russians over president relative
possibility the very real possibility
that President Putin holds damaging
information
/ President Trump Trump's eagerness to
sellout America proves the Russians must
have something personally politically or
financially on President Trump
it proves that Trump is committing
treason think about what you just saw
the last person in that montage was
Nancy Pelosi as you know she's the
Speaker of the House third in line from
the presidency
she's the country's most powerful
lawmaker supposedly a wise and sober
person and if there she was telling you
it's been proved that the president
United States is working for a hostile
foreign power as any speaker in American
history ever said something that
irresponsible maybe nothing comes to
mind
but if you think that's shocking
consider this Pelosi is still saying
that our investigative producer Alex
fight for ran into Pelosi just this
afternoon on Capitol Hill and asked her
listen to what she told our show
speaker Pelosi Alex backer of temporal
sentai in January wondered what Putin
had on Trump after yesterday any closer
to figure that out
we have open the courts right you know
are you any closer to figuring out like
what Putin has on Trump that's why we
need to have what they have to answer
our subpoena you still it might have
some sort of blackmail on the president
I wonder what the Putin has politically
financially or personally the exchange
isn't long but it really tells you
everything you need to know Pelosi
told our show the president is a traitor
who is committing treason and yet she
doesn't want to impeach him how does
that make sense well it only makes sense
when you understand that Pelosi doesn't
mean a single word that she says
everything is political meaning it's
only about power that's not just
annoying it's also ominous and here's
why
15 years ago this spring we invaded a
rock to stop a WMD program that didn't
exist thousands of American troops died
in the process trillions of dollars were
wasted it was the single greatest
mistake in this country in generations
and yet and here's the key nobody in
Washington was ever punished for it the
people who planned it went on to even
better jobs one of them is now a
national security adviser John Bolton
five years after the Iraq war our
economy collapsed remember that the
subprime meltdown the specific causes
were complex but the themes were
instantly recognizable greed and
stupidity and yet once again no one was
ever punished now fast-forward another
11 years to today right now America
stands on the brink of yet more foolish
foreign entanglements and on the brink
of potentially another financial
meltdown why is that because nobody in
Washington has learned anything and why
would they learn anything when they
screw up there are never any
consequences they skate by on the usual
mixture of aggression and BS nothing to
see here keep moving imagine for a
second what would happen if you let your
kids act like that well they'd be in
prison by now so maybe it's time to stop
the cycle in Washington how about this
if you get caught lying about the big
things whether it's about weapons
destruction or subprime mortgages or
Russian collusion you have to admit it
and surf penance not necessarily prison
time though we're open but punishment of
some kind you can't stay in Washington
making six times the average American
salary you can't do that no sorry you've
got to leave
you got to relocate to Camden New Jersey
maybe or Gary Indiana and do something
useful like clean motel rooms for
minimum wage put the little sanitized
for your protection strips on toilets
not forever just for a decade or two
until you've learned your lesson
call us when you've done that but not
before